Conseil national de la refondation
Elisabeth dono cette concertation c'est
la bonne solution face à l'urgence de la
situation
je crois que c'est une solution pour
mettre en face les élus les
professionnels de santé avec la
population qui a besoin
d'éclaircissement qui a besoin de
comprendre pourquoi on en est arrivé là
finalement parce que les difficultés
sont nombreuses il suffit pas de claquer
des doigts pour avoir des médecins issus
pas de claques et des doigts pour que
les urgences soient fluides enfin que
tout se passe bien non il y a quand même
un certain nombre de paramètres et on a
besoin de se frotter les uns aux autres
de comprendre pour justement admettre
que la situation ne va pas se régler en
un éclair est-ce qu'on en est encore à
Patrick Pelot au temps du constat de la
concertation où est-ce que c'est du
temps perdu sur la recherche de
solutions et surtout sur leur
application
on doit pas avoir
on doit pas avoir une mémoire de poisson
rouge on doit s'inspirer de l'histoire
comme vient de dire madame la sénatrice
et c'est très important comment on en
est arrivé là comment une des plus
grandes puissances du monde qui avait le
meilleur système de santé au monde et
est venu un des pays où la mortalité
materno infantile du périnatal
c'est-à-dire des suites de couches et
l'une des plus catastrophiques au monde
c'est pas rien d'accord bon ben je crois
que là si on ne fait pas ce travail de
se dire on a fait des erreurs dans le
passé il faut les corriger on y arrivera
pas là quand le ministre dit je veux un
médecin traitant pour tous mais c'est
quasiment impossible vous avez plusieurs
millions de personnes qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant et du coup ce que fait
le folle au Mans il a raison il dit je
fais une maison médicale pour accueillir
ce combat de médecin traitant c'est vrai
ce qui veut dire au lieu de dire on va
continuer à essayer cette course vers
tout le monde un médecin traitant aurait
mieux voir autrement les choses et là
vous retomber sur le fait que
on a fait une erreur grave en 2007 avec
la loi HPST on a enlevé aux élus la
présidence du conseil d'administration
des hôpitaux or les élus donc la fameuse
politique de territoire et ça moi
j'adhère totalement à l'idée de dire que
ça doit partir des territoires ils
avaient le sens il savait et d'ailleurs
vous avez vu quand il y a eu la campagne
présidentielle qui a eu ses
confrontations avec les élus
territoriaux etc le premier sujet
c'était la santé bon si vous n'avez pas
et vous remettez pas les mers les élus
sur une directive de la santé vous n'y
arriverez pas or on a pris en 2007 on a
enlevé les élus des conseils
d'administration c'est le fameux concept
qui avait Nicolas Sarkozy Rosine
Bachelot de dire l'hôpital l'entreprise
l'hôpital est en concurrence etc on a
tout cassé deuxièmement on a cassé un
truc hyper important concernant les
hôpitaux on a cassé les services or
c'était la cellule ouvrière on a mis des
pôles pour faire des espèce de monstres
difformes avec que des querelles parce
qu'en plus de ça vous avez beaucoup de
narcissiques pervers qui se sont dit je
suis maître du monde en étant chef de
pôle ça a pas été dans le sens collectif
ce qui fait que quand vous avez cette ce
que dit votre collègue du Mans là il
manque 50 praticiens dans les hôpitaux
c'est partout pareil et après quand vous
vous tournez alors là ça c'est quand
vous vous tournez vers Pôle emploi et
que vous dites mais vous avez combien
d'infirmières qui sont à Pôle emploi
alors là vous tombez de votre chaise
3000 dans le Lot donc comment se fait-il
que le personnel a quitté l'hôpital et
préfère être au chômage plutôt que de
travailler à l'hôpital parce que on a ça
il y avait une statistique de la du
ministère qui disait qu'il y avait à peu
près 60 000 infirmières qui étaient à
Pôle emploi
60000 vous rendez compte là on est en
échec total avec parcoursup sur la
formation des infirmières vous avez 40%
des infirmières qu'il a ne termine pas
leurs études donc il y a vraiment des
sujets absolument majeurs mais ça sert à
rien de pérenniser des systèmes qui ne
marchent pas ce qu'a dit le ministre
d'ailleurs mais faut pas qu'il soit
contradictoire avec lui-même mais le
chantier si on vous écoute ah le
chantier ou c'est beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus qu'à l'échelle d'un
quinquennat si il termine le quinquennat
dynamique il faut prendre le temps de se
parler de ce comprendre et d'avoir les
mêmes conditions en quelque sorte parce
que la dynamique c'est ce qui va attirer
des médecins qui va tirer des
infirmières qui va créer quelque chose
qui qui va pouvoir fonctionner en fait
on met de l'huile dans les rouages quand
on travaille là-dessus sur le territoire
de la Mayenne qui était en aussi grande
difficulté que celui de la Sarthe nous
avons beaucoup travaillé justement avec
les intercommunalités aujourd'hui il y a
des maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
partout il y a aussi des centres de
santé là où justement il y a plus besoin
d'un médecin traitant parce qu'il y a
une population qui n'en a pas mais vous
savez quand on regarde la Suède moi j'ai
fait un voyage de quelques jours avec la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Catherine Deroche il y a que
30% des Suédois qui ont un médecin
traitant alors évidemment se comparer
c'est pas se consoler comme dit l'adage
mais néanmoins on voit bien que toute
tous les pays de l'hémisphère Nord n'ont
pas fait ce constat cette planification
une population qui vieillit une
population avec des polytraumatismes des
polypes pathologies et puis en face des
projets de santé qui sont pas là
suffisamment en nombre donc il faut se
dire qu'on est pas seul dans la galère
c'est c'est partout dans le monde on
manque de médecin politique d'avoir à
tout prix un médecin traitant c'est pas
la bonne en fait mais peut-être que oui
mais on peut peut-être considérer que le
médecin traitant il est dans la
communauté professionnelle territoriale
de santé c'est pas forcément un seul
médecin mais c'est un des médecins de la
maison de santé pluridisciplinaire ou du
territoire c'est c'est là où vous
arrivez à ce concept du dossier médical
partagé que voulait la sécurité sociale
depuis des années qui est extrêmement
compliqué à faire les Anglais ont essayé
de le faire ils ont renoncé tellement
l'outil informatique et complexe bon
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
s'écarter de ça il y a une intrication
et ses multifactorielle sur cette crise
c'est pour ça qu'on essaye et c'est très
difficile dans des discours de quelques
minutes de faire la synthèse pour ça
pourquoi pas le choix politique a été de
faire ce conseil national et de faire
des réunions bon à allons-y travaillons
sur le truc mais par exemple on peut pas
rester en étant la France malgré les
mesures et l'augmentation qui avait eu
au moment du Ségur de rester pour les
personnels
non médicaux c'est-à-dire les
infirmières les aides soignants etc pour
les discerner ils sont médicaux mais
c'est une appellation de
commune de les appeler comme ça on les a
augmenté de 190 euros bon mais je crois
que là il y a un problème des salaires
on est toujours à la 18e place des pays
de l'OCDE or travailler et vouloir
travailler à Paris parce que tout est là
sur les grandes villes tout est assez
grande ville vous ne pouvez pas vivre
dans les grandes villes avec moins de
2000 euros par mois c'est impossible
impossible et alors après si vous mettez
la charge de travail par rapport à la
permanence de soins et des métiers où
vous travaillez le week-end la nuit etc
les infirmières c'est 1,07 de plus de
l'heure par la nuit c'est pas possible
et si vous n'avez pas cette question de
l'augmentation massive au Québec ils ont
résolu le problème ils ont augmenté de
30% les salaires les effectifs étaient
plein je pense que c'est la même
stratégie qu'il faut avoir en France je
suis totalement d'accord surtout pour
les urgences parce que c'était ça le
sujet de fait il y a des contraintes il
y a des astreintes là il faut mettre le
paquet si on veut avoir des
professionnels en tout cas des jeunes
qui sont tentés par ces professions et
toute façon quand vous avez donné cet
argent aux personnel ça va relancer une
partie de la consommation parce qu'ils
vont ils ont tellement de besoins et
cette augmentation de 30% c'est pas
énorme
on va faire le point justement sur la
crise dans les services d'urgence
d'abord Alex avec vous les chiffres
crises qui se confirment sur tout le
territoire dans de nombreuses
établissements mais oui et les derniers
mois ont été très compliqué pour nos
urgences hospitalières si on prend le
mois d'août dernier 25% des services
d'urgence on réduit ou fermé leur accès
selon une consultation réalisée par le
syndicat SAMU urgence de France
concernant les smurs les services
d'urgence mobile et de réanimation 24%
ont été dans l'obligation de fermer une
ligne durant le mois d'août et puis il y
a les fermetures de services il y a
également des capacités de lit qui
diminuent en 2021 4400 litres
d'hospitalisation complète ont été
supprimés c'est fermeture de lit elles
sont causées en grande partie par manque
de personnel manque de médecins d'abord
au mois de juillet 2022 90% des services
d'urgence a déclaré manqué de médecins
pour accueillir traiter les patients et
puis aussi manque d'infirmiers en 2021
12 départements ont dû faire fonctionner
leurs hôpitaux avec moins de 50
infirmiers pour à 10000 habitants on
peut citer des départements
d'Ile-de-France comme le Val-d'Oise la
Seine-et-Marne à la scène à Saint-Denis
mais également elle adoredogne ce sont
la Haute-Corse la Creuse et Mayotte qui
sont les départements avec le moins
d'infirmés merci Alex pour ces chiffres
alors ce sont des chiffres évidemment
posent bien la situation Patrick nous
vous quête dans ce quotidien là comment
ça se passe aujourd'hui concrètement
dans les services d'urgence
la situation s'est aggravée
évidemment si vous voulez quand on a
lancé les alertes d'ailleurs qu'un
certain François Braun avant qu'il soit
mini ministre lançait avec nous d'accord
cet été a été épouvantable alors
évidemment les médias vous attendiez des
grandes rames des morts partout etc
c'est pas comme ça c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe mais déjà travailler
avec ces 25% de fermeture de services
d'urgence c'est le jeu des dominos c'est
à dire tout s'est écroulé il y a un
sujet par exemple absolument dramatique
dont on ne parle pas c'est l'hôpital de
Corbeil qui a été hacké il est fermé
depuis plusieurs semaines et donc ça
vous déstabilise tout le sud ouest de
l'Île-de-France d'accord c'est le jeu
des dominos d'accord et ça interpelle
sur le fait et alors j'ai appris parce
que j'étais dans le Lot avec les élus du
Lot j'ai appris qu'il y a deux hôpitaux
qui ont été hackés donc il y a un
véritable danger là c'est une parenthèse
de donner c'est vraiment une c'est la
souveraineté du pays pour moi c'est un
véritable acte de terrorisme mais donc
la catastrophe elle est là et au
quotidien c'est difficile je vous prends
un exemple parce que on parle du monde
rural mais on peut parler de la
Pitié-Salpêtrière par exemple qui est le
l'immense hôpital la plus grands
hôpitaux d'Europe et ben qu'est-ce qu'on
nous a demandé il y a 24 heures
d'arrêter d'envoyer des patients avec
des actes chirurgicaux orthopédiques
parce que les chirurgiens orthopédistes
ont démissionné voyez donc c'est une
réalité et si vous regardez
l'effondrement de la chirurgie publique
s'il y avait un exemple à donner c'est
la chirurgie orthopédique qui a
quasiment basculé entièrement vers le
privé et vous apercevez ça c'est
intéressant que tous ceux qui avaient la
théorie de dire basculons dans le privé
lucratif ça ira mieux pas du tout ça ne
change rien et c'est pour ça que là si
vous voulez l'alerte elle est profonde
parce que
les épidémies sont en train d'arriver et
évidemment comme à toute période de
l'automne c'est les enfants qui
commencent vous avez vu l'article dans
le monde il y a quelques jours et on est
obligé de transférer des enfants
d'Île-de-France vers Rouen et c'est
comme ça en fait partout il y a des
départements il y a plus de pédiatre on
va voir comment ça se passe en Mayenne
chez vous Elisabeth lannault la
situation est aussi critique et bien
écoutez le service des urgences c'est en
intermittence je dirais depuis déjà
quelques mois et l'ensemble des
professionnels sont mobilisés alors moi
je leur rends hommage parce que vraiment
travailler dans ces conditions c'est
compliqué pour la population c'est aussi
très difficile parce que faut presque
regarder l'agenda voilà le calendrier
des ouvertures
mais je sais qu'on est pas seul mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est-ce que l'on
fait qu'est-ce qu'on apporte comme
solution alors moi je crois
effectivement la solution de la
rémunération parce que il faut attirer
des jeunes dans ces professions là on
voit qu'aujourd'hui c'est tellement
pénible
cette pression constante sur le dos de
faire 150% de travail plutôt que ce que
100%, ça peut durer quelques jours mais
ça ne peut pas durer sur la sur la
semaine et donc il y a un certain nombre
de professionnels qui démissionne qui
partent ailleurs il ne trouve plus de
sens à travailler dans cette urgence
c'est et dans cette comment difficulté
constante du manque de professionnel à
leur côté donc il faut absolument mettre
le paquet sur la rémunération je suis
d'accord et avant tout sur les urgences
et services là service de réanimation
aussi parce que on a vu combien pendant
la crise sanitaire on en a eu besoin et
puis je pense aussi qu'il faut
planifier un grand plan de rénovation de
nos établissements hospitaliers parce
que bien sûr il y a eu la partie Ségur
investissement et il y a quelques mois
mais je crois qu'il faut tous les ans
aujourd'hui consacré une somme
importante à la rénovation de notre
hôpital parce que l'hôpital c'est aussi
c'est c'est le lieu emblématique d'une
ville
il y a l'hôtel de ville mais le pital il
a une place particulière et on sait que
la santé c'est le sujet qui tient au
cœur des Français
parce que par exemple quand vous prenez
la permanence des soins le cadeau fiscal
qui a été fait au monde libéral et c'est
très bien et bravo à leur syndicat de
l'avoir obtenu c'est la défiscalisation
de 70 jours par an du travail de la
permanence de soins du bon ça fait quand
même pour au minimum 40 000 à 70 000
euros par an qui sont donnés aux
médecins libéraux qui font un travail de
permanence de soins qui mérite d'être
payé mais à côté de ça ceux qui
travaillent dans l'hôpital public ils
sont fiscalisés quand vous quand on a
fait le covid et qu'on a tous travaillé
comme des fous café le gouvernement il
nous a dit bon vous serez défiscalisé
des heures supplémentaires donc tout le
monde a travaillé plus puis après en
fait non on nous a mis un plafond vous
avez mis un plafond de 5000 balles
d'accord Bing et donc du coup en gros si
vous voulez cette année on a rendu tout
l'argent qu'on fait travailler en plus
ça démoralise deuxièmement concernant
les urgences ce qui attirait les
urgences qui est très intéressant moi je
l'ai vu avec plein de collègues ayant un
peu vécu maintenant
c'était des collègues qui venaient aux
urgences et puis qui après faisait autre
chose mais gardez attache aux urgences
quand est né la spécialité et c'est pour
ça que nous on était assez réservé par
rapport à ça et tomber l'exclusivité du
travail aux urgences
l'urgentiste etc voilà avec avec
beaucoup de collègues qui ont montré des
muscles en disant on est très fort on
est spécialistes qu'a sorti le Conseil
de l'Ordre l'année dernière Conseil de
l'Ordre il a dit si vous êtes urgentiste
travailler plus qu'aux urgences et au
SAMU vous pouvez plus faire permanence
de soins vous pouvez plus faire autre
chose ce qui fait que il y a beaucoup de
collègues qui sont dit mais alors
attends je vais vieillir en répondant au
standard du Samu toute ma vie je vais
vieillir en étant de garde les samedis
les dimanches les jours fériés pour
gagner un peu plus il faut que je sois
en bonne santé vieillissement des
urgences très difficile parce que c'est
un métier à stress donc d'un coup une
prévalence plus importante de toutes les
maladies chroniques bon ils ont réfléchi
et beaucoup sont partis et beaucoup de
jeunes en formation ont dit à mes mois
je voudrais faire autre chose aussi ils
ont arrêté faut revoir cette exclusivité
des disciplines et la réponse des après
on va voir l'exemple de Mulhouse
totalement d'agilité et de plasticité
notre pays en fait il faut accorder des
des commandes des temps à l'hôpital
comme des temps à la médecine de ville
des temps en médecin généraliste comme
des temps un médecin urgentiste en fait
il faut avoir cette capacité à offrir
aux professionnels des pratiques
différentes parce que c'est aussi des
respirations vous voyez dans la vie
professionnelle c'est très important ça
et c'est pour ça que le pouvoir
politique doit être un contre-pouvoir au
pouvoir des doyens et de l'université je
comprends l'indépendance de l'université
mais il y a un moment si vous analysez
bien le merdier dans lequel on est au
point de vue médical en France il y a
une responsabilité du monde
universitaire qui n'assume pas du tout
se retournant systématiquement sur le
politique en disant c'est de votre faute
alors je suis étant vraiment dans le
monde universitaire
je ben oui je vous assure il faut un
contre-pouvoir plus fort des doyens mais
en tout cas au moins qu'on soit au même
niveau et vous voulez jouer une anecdote
pendant la crise du on montait on
manquait de réanimateur médico on est
monté jusqu'au plus haut degré de l'État
voire Jean Castex en lui disant on ne
peut pas rester à former que 76
réanimateurs médicaux en France chaque
année Jean Castex a parfaitement compris
il y a il a il s'est méfié de ce qu'on
disait c'est normal c'est son jeu il a
fait il a fait il a mis des spécialistes
etc il nous a dit vous avez raison je
vais augmenter le nombre de réanimateurs
médicaux il n'a pas pu le faire par
blocage du monde hospitalo universitaire
en forme 475 anesthésiste réanimateur
par an ces derniers réanimateurs non non
75% partent dans le privé on va
continuer à parler des solutions on va
aller voir à Mulhouse Mulhouse qui a
cherché évidemment des solutions pour
désengorger les urgences et quand un
calmer nous y emmène on va voir qu'une
unité mobile de télémédecine a été mise
en place
Lucile et Alexandre sont tous les deux
infirmiers en mission pour le 15 on
prend notre mallette d'abord à
l'intérieur il y a de quoi faire le
bilan devant cette équipement un service
médical mobile permet de mener
directement une consultation complète
chez le patient qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive monsieur
[Musique]
un homme de 68 ans souffrant de fièvre
et de difficultés respiratoires très
vite le verdict tombe
à la vitesse à laquelle il se positive
une fois tous ces examens réalisés ils
sont transmis au médecin à distance un
équipement qui permet même aux
praticiens d'écouter la respiration de
ce malade je vous mets ensuite parce
mieux que la téléconsultation
on a le patient en face de soi et rien
du tout là ça permet d'avoir des vrais
éléments pour pouvoir évaluer le patient
on a déjà toutes les toutes les
constantes on peut avoir la pression
artérielle la fréquence cardiaque la
saturation
cette initiative a été lancée le 22 août
dernier en plein pic de la crise des
hôpitaux elle permet de participer à
désengorger des urgences saturées sur
toutes les interventions que j'ai fait
il y a plus de 80% des gens qu'on a
laissé à domicile il y a malheureusement
quelques fois ou ben on peut pas
échapper on est obligé de d'hospitaliser
le patient à Mulhouse c'est ici que sont
reçus les appels au 15 dans cette salle
cet après-midi trois opérateurs
répondent aux appels et les transferts
après un premier filtre au médecin
régulateur vous avez plusieurs
personnels présents H24 bien sûr avec
des performances qui prennent l'appel
initialement et qui font un tri très
rapidement entre ce qu'on appelle
urgent ou non urgent l'appel par la
suite est transmis au médecin
révélateurs qui sont juste en face
nous avons deux médecins régulateurs en
journée et en médecine régulateur
présent la nuit ce sont donc ces
médecins qui décident pour les urgences
non vitales d'envoyer l'unité mobile de
télémédecine pour le médecin régulateur
c'est un nouvel outil qu'il faut
apprendre à maîtriser donc finalement
faut apprendre à avoir les bonnes
indications pour quel patient ce sera
efficace pour pas qu'il y ait tout de
même après la visite un passage à
l'hôpital donc là si le patient reste à
la maison après la consultation c'est
qu'on est dans la bonne indication donc
c'est des un nouvel outil à s'approprier
au fil du temps cette expérimentation
est cofinancée par l'ARS l'agence
régionale de santé du Grand Est
l'assurance maladie se sont ainsi une
quinzaine de départements qui l'amène et
elle est concluante dans le Bas-Rhin
dans ce dispositif là 75% des personnes
qui ont été vues ne vont pas aux
urgences finalement donc ça veut dire
veut dire qu'on atteint l'objectif pour
d'éviter que les patients se déplacent
et d'éviter de faire perdre tout le
monde du temps aux urgences on est le
seul département dans lequel on a eu
aucun jour blanc sans intervention donc
on sait d'ores et déjà que ça fonctionne
que c'est adapté qu'on en a besoin le
gouvernement entendirait les leçons de
cette expérience à l'automne mais les
professionnels du secteur sont lucides
ces unités mobiles de télémédecine sont
une goutte d'eau face à la crise globale
de l'hôpital public et on voit cet
exemple de Muse ça peut être une bonne
solution ça Élisabeth Denault pour des
engorger les urgences les unités mobiles
de télémédecine et bien écoutez moi
j'avais pas connaissance de celle de
Muse j'avais plutôt de la Manche en tête
et j'avais plutôt de bons échos j'avais
d'ailleurs un directeur de la protection
civile en Mayenne qui s'était proposée
pour mettre les choses en place bon moi
je pense que c'est une solution
effectivement qu'il faut peut-être
user mais pas trop utiliser en réalité
parce qu'on sait très très bien que ça
ne remplacera pas ce qui était la
habituelle donc la télémédecine c'était
bien pendant la situation de la crise
sanitaire et on a vu que ça pouvait
rendre des services maintenant il faut
pas trop développer ou en tout cas des
conditions qui sont correctes d'appel
d'offres de marché bien identifié et
puis surtout de faire des bilans
réguliers pour voir si effectivement
reste toujours sur cette proposition d'à
peu près 70% de personnes qui vont
rester au domicile finalement et ne pas
encombrer les urgences et 30% qui vont
être effectivement amenés à rencontrer
les services d'urgence
très grande méfiance sur ces évolutions
brutales qui d'un coup serait la
solution pour tout si ça reste
associatif c'est c'est ça peut être bien
à but non lucratif ça c'est très bien et
si ça dépend du service public je pense
que ça c'est c'est le gage quelque part
de sécurité bon faut faire très
attention parce que si vous voyez ce que
ce qu'il ne faut pas c'est que en fait
les gens riches ou bien placés dans des
endroits où il y a une surmédic verront
toujours des docteurs et puis ceux qui
ou pour pallier la carence on va prendre
un système qui s'apparente quand même à
une sorte d'ubérisation du système de
santé pour dire finalement vous verrez
autre chose et à Jane que pourra alors
ça fait pas baisser la fréquentation des
urgences ça fait pas baisser la
fréquentation des urgences parce que en
fait en gros les gens qui restent à
domicile bah ils auraient vu leur
médecin traitant etc donc il y a une
notion de rapidité parce qu'ils ont
appelé à avoir les les personnes donc
c'est très relatif c'est très relatif
mais ce sont des nouveaux outils qu'il
faut qu'on prenne je crois que si vous
laissez téléconsultation c'était les
médecines elles ont tout un intérêt sur
les malades chroniques et déjà connu
c'est pour ça que la sécurité sociale
avait dit au départ on fait de la
téléconsultation pour les malades
chroniques le médecin les connaît il les
a ils voient cela sur l'urgence on est
quand même beaucoup plus réservé
d'accord et il faut pas se laisser
dériver sous prétexte qu'on a un
problème pour trouver des médecins de
dire finalement ça viendra moins cher en
mettant des infirmiers et puis
finalement on a une espèce de déclin
lent et majestueux sur le nombre de
nécessaires de médecins en France et
justement un mot sur cette question
d'être déserts un texte examiné au Sénat
dans 10 jours à l'accent mais oui les
sénateurs les républicains qui vont
défendre une proposition de loi pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux avec
une mesure très simple rajouter une
quatrième année à l'internat au
troisième cycle des études de médecine
et cette quatrième année elle sera
réalisée en priorité en stage dans les
territoires sous dotés en médecins c'est
une mesure qui permettra selon les
sénateurs de droite de déployer 3900
médecins internes dans ces territoires
et pour la droite sénatoriale c'est un
dispositif qui est obéit à une logique
nouvelle face aux aides aux actions
ponctuelles qui n'ont pas permis par le
passé bien d'attirer ces jeunes médecins
dans les déserts médicaux c'est un débat
qui va avoir lieu au Sénat le 18 octobre
et le gouvernement a le même type de
mesure dans les dans les cartons c'est
une bonne solution dans le budget de la
Sécu d'ailleurs c'est une bonne solution
alors je sais pas si c'est la solution
pour répondre aux problèmes des déserts
médicaux à la effectivement on va
proposer à ces jeunes d'aller dans des
territoires soudés et d'aller auprès
d'un médecin senior et d'exercer et
peut-être de ce familiariser à cette
pratique et surtout au territoire sur
lequel il va être mais à mon avis il
faut quand même s'interroger sur
l'harmonisation des études de médecine
en Europe par exemple parce que là c'est
vraiment la difficulté je redis ce que
j'ai vu en Suède en fait chaque année
désormais ils ont la moitié des
étudiants en médecine enfin qui
deviennent médecins qui sont formés dans
d'autres pays et en majorité la Pologne
ou la Hongrie je crois pour la Suède
mais nous c'est pareil on a des jeunes
qui viennent de Belgique qui viennent de
Roumanie et donc la première chose à
faire il me semble ce qui était le plus
urgent c'était cette harmonisation parce
que maintenant aussi il y a chez les
jeunes cette envie de mobilité il nous
reste 30 secondes Patrick polo 30
secondes il faut casser la loi 1958 sur
les CHU et faire que les étudiants
puissent aller faire des stages dans les
hôpitaux généraux vous êtes enfermé sur
les CHU pour les former et du coup
évidemment ils ne vont pas voir ailleurs
donc du coup et je pense que c'est une
mauvaise idée cette quatrième année
parce qu'on punit les jeunes générations
en leur disant vous allez refaire une
année supplémentaire et on punit les
jeunes moi je pense que c'est autre
chose c'est justement les maisons
pluridisciplinaires c'est le travail en
commun sur les territoires de santé ces
données du sens de collaboration et de
coopération entre les systèmes sinon on
y arrivera pas en fait merci beaucoup on
aurait encore plein de sujets abordé
c'est on va ce sujet malheureusement il
nous reste peu de temps on va juste
regarder ce qu'elle a une de nos
quotidien régionaux
[Musique]